- This is the Morpeth Roll.
It's about as tall as
the Empire State Building,
and it's three and a half times the length
of a football field.
- [Man] The Morpeth Roll,
essentially, is a thank you note
to Lord Morpeth, who
was the Chief Secretary
of Ireland from about 1835 to '41.
- [Woman] It was estimated at the time
that it had 270,000 signatures.
- Making it one of the
largest such testimonials
in existence provided to
George Howard Vica Morpeth.
- I am Quinton Atkinson,
senior director of global
content at Ancestry;
and this is the archival
vault at Ancestry.
The content team is responsible
for finding out where
documents exist throughout
the world that could provide
discoveries for people.
We then digitize records, and then
we create searchable indexes.
The Morpeth Roll is
important because it captures
a group of people in
Ireland pre the 1845 famine,
but also because in 1922,
a lot of the records
documenting people within
Ireland were destroyed by fire
during the Civil War of Ireland.
The Morpeth Roll really
is a census substitute
for those that lived at
that time in Ireland.
- I am Professor Terence Dooley,
principal investigator of
the Morpeth Roll Project.
The Morpeth Roll is a
token of gratitude for the
reforms that have been
introduced to Ireland
by Lord Morpeth.
On the presentation of the
gift itself, Morpeth decides
to bring it back to his home
at Castle Howard in Yorkshire,
and there it remains for 180 years.
- That is until 2009 when
the Lord Morpeth Roll was
discovered in the Castle Howard archives.
- My name is Louise Walsworth-Bell.
I'm a paper conservator and
part of the team that worked
on the Morpeth Roll.
Well this is the spool on which
the Morpeth Roll was rolled,
and it would have fitted into this chest.
There are enormous difficulties
with handling a document
of that size, so it's really
important that we would make
the object handleable.
Digitization has massively
facilitated research.
- The beauty of coming to
Ancestry is that I can type in the
name of an ancestor I'm
looking for, we search then
all of the documents that we
have, and if we find a match,
you can click on the
image and actually see
that digital image.
Ancestry has probably
created electronic indexes
from handwritten documents
more than anyone else in the world.
We use an overhead digital
camera with lighting to
highlight the writing
on the page and move it
a frame at a time, so that
we can make sure we preserve
every stroke of the pen,
every color variation in the
parchment.
At the end, after we've
captured every single image,
those are stitched together
in a document that now appears online.
- [Woman] I think the beauty
of the digitization of the roll
by Ancestry is it enables
access not only here within
Ireland but worldwide, so
it becomes accessible.
- This roll actually reaches
out now to a much wider
international community.
- [Man] The records that the
content team at Ancestry are
searching out and digitizing
range from yearbooks
with photos in them to
the military file of your
great-grandfather as he
served in World War I.
Whatever the record type, our
goal is to bring you the richest
experience of connecting
with your ancestor.
(Irish highlands music)